[Música]
economía en directo américa me acompaña
en el estudio jorge hurtado jorge muy
buenas noches vamos a comenzar hablando
de esa situación en los aeropuertos y de
algunas aerolíneas en europa un caos
total viajar en vacaciones en europa
para que tengas en cuenta para tus
próximas vacaciones europea bueno
actualmente existe una crisis laboral en
varios aeropuertos de europa debido a la
huelga de los trabajadores sobre mejores
condiciones salariales el sector afirma
que la aviación europea en su conjunto
ha perdido 600.000 puestos de trabajo
desde el inicio de la pandemia pero las
contrataciones no llegan lo
suficientemente rápido como para acabar
con el riesgo de vuelos cancelados y
largas espera también para los viajeros
los aeropuertos de alemania francia
españa los países bajos intentan ofrecer
ventajas como aumentos de sueldo y
primas a los trabajadores que
recomienden incluso amigos para poder
trabajar ahí el problema está santiago
porque ahora mismo inicia la temporada
de verano en el que los viajes aéreos
debían volver a la normalidad tras dos
años caídos por la pandemia la escasez
de mano de obra y la huelga ya han
afectado los viajes en londres ámsterdam
parís roma y frankfurt mientras se
planifica en bélgica españa francia y
escandinavia que podrían afectar a miles
de viajeros escuchemos cuáles son las
principales exigencias de estos
trabajadores
nuestro movimiento se basa en un
problema vinculado en particular a una
solicitud de contratación un problema
sobre los salarios en particular todos
los bonos que no se han revalorizado
desde antes del cobi
esperábamos un aumento general del 6 por
ciento tras un año de negociaciones
tenemos vamos a decir que tal vez sea
mixto respetamos las opciones
democráticas
sigo pensando en mis vacaciones europeas
y me pregunto cuál es pero bueno
hablemos de esta situación cómo puede
afectar entonces a los viajeros en
europa bueno santiago el sector de la
aviación afirma haber perdido 2,3
millones de puestos de trabajo en todo
el mundo durante la pandemia lo más
afectado los servicios de asistencia en
tierra y seguridad según el grupo de
acción del transporte aéreo que
representa a ese sector las compañías
aéreas se ven obligadas a recortar miles
de vuelos de sus horarios de verano para
hacer frente a las interrupciones entre
ellas british airways lufthansa y
también easyjet e incluso los
aeropuertos han pedido a las aerolíneas
que reduzcan la cantidad de pasajeros
diarios para tratar de aliviar esta
presión que vive el ministerio de
transporte británico pidió apoyo a las
aerolíneas para evitar que se repitieran
las residentes decenas que vivimos de
caos en los aeropuertos y les pidió que
aplicaran horarios de verano realistas
entre comidas realistas a la crisis
laboral que atraviesan alemania también
prometió acelerar el visado para
trabajadores aeroportuarios extranjeros
mientras que portugal y españa- esperan
reforzar la planilla países bajo
prometió por ejemplo pagar más por las
horas durante el verano todo para evitar
las molestias de los pasajeros que a
propósito esto es lo que opinan
estoy un poco molesto pero en realidad
respeto que la gente haga huelga si no
les gusta algo no sé cómo ha sucedido
porque en ucrania no es algo habitual no
tenemos este tipo de huelgas pero
realmente respeto que la gente haga eso
y
no supimos que se había cancelado hasta
que llegamos al aeropuerto ha sido un
poco molesto pero creo que podemos
arreglarnos las ong's vimos esto es del
lado de los aeropuertos vimos esto desde
el lado de los viajeros ahora cuál es el
papel de las aerolíneas santiago los
ejecutivos de las aerolíneas afirman que
son conscientes de que es difícil cubrir
las plazas para puestos que son
exigentes físicamente y todavía mal
pagados otro problema es que la
formación del personal y las
autorizaciones de seguridad para
trabajar en los aeropuertos llevan meses
en poderse aprobar por ejemplo los
aeropuertos parisinos necesitan cubrir
4.000 puestos de trabajo principalmente
en seguridad mantenimiento y venta de
viajes muchos trabajadores rechazan
volver a sus puestos porque son atraídos
por trabajos a corto plazo o están
optando por la jubilación anticipada
en cualquiera de los casos el verano
europeo no será el soñado regreso por
pandemia que muchos esperaban y quienes
viajen probablemente tendrán que
enfrentarse a retrasos por esta crisis
laboral que atraviesa europa jorge vale
la pena preguntarse las aerolíneas
europeas que tienen conexión con américa
latina' cómo afecta esto entonces a los
viajeros que salen desde los hoops de
conexiones de latinoamérica hacia europa
también se ven afectados estos vuelos
estos pasajeros sin duda alguna porque
la situación no tiene que ver tanto con
las aerolíneas sino más bien con los
aeropuertos que se han visto en los
últimos días hemos visto huelgas en los
aeropuertos parisinos también en
amsterdam
ha habido inclusive en portugal que es
uno de los principales destinos
turísticos de europa y esta situación
según lo que dicen los expertos que se
va a continuar repitiendo aunque pase el
verano que es digamos la temporada alta
en europa por la situación de la crisis
laboral lo que se pregunta uno jorge es
previendo que en el verano iba a volar
tanta gente como las aerolíneas no
organizaron sus planillas de trabajo
previendo que estará la temporada para
recuperarse después de la pandemia de
kobe 19 muchas gracias punto final en
economía jorge ha continua el debate
siempre en directo américa